by Laurie Garrett who senior fellow for
global health at the Council on Foreign
Relations only her most recent of many
stellar accomplishments this is as you
know a lecture in the Hertog global
strategy initiative seminar series this
lecture series is sponsored by the
Hertog global strategy initiative and
the her talk family thank you to roger
Hertog for the funding co-sponsored by
the center for the history and ethics of
public health at the Melman school and
the Department of History and we thank
the Communications Office at the Melman
school for the refreshments tonight I
also wanted to tell you for those of you
for whom one lecture is not enough of
course we have these weekly but there's
also a course that Sarah bergstresser is
offering the second session the new
session is starting on July 5th through
August 11th and that's available through
summer sessions so those of you who
would like to also have a discussion to
go with it you can register two credits
and information is available on the
Hertog website or the columbia summer
sessions website and it's open to all
Columbia students it's truly a pleasure
and a privilege to welcome Laurie
Garrett here tonight she of course is
well known she has won every award in
journalism the Pulitzer the Peabody the
pulk
and then after that of course there was
nothing left to do so she moved on to
run the program in global health at the
Council on Foreign Relations where there
where she has really been able to expand
I think her palate beyond the many
classics she's already provided and and
given us she has a new book coming out
many of you I hope are already familiar
with her classic books the coming plague
newly emerging diseases in a world out
of balance which remains
every time I go into the bookstore I can
still find copies on the shelf so I
highly recommend it and really a classic
in the field and followed up by betrayal
of trust the collapse of global public
health which indeed I think was an
appropriate lead-in to her current
interest in the future of global health
a serious situation which which
obviously involves the kind of serious
thinking that Laurie Garrett can can
bring to it and for that reason we're
particularly delighted to welcome you
here tonight she also has another book
coming out it's going to be published
electronically in about two weeks I
understand I could hear the sirens
scream America's response to 9/11 and as
the other books there will be many
interesting revelations and I think much
very good writing so to give you a
chance to experience what Laurie Garrett
has to say and I think a very special
treat for us tonight on the future of
global health Laurie Garrett thank you
thank you for coming this evening and I
know that your focus here in this series
is on pandemics I will I will touch on
it but I hope I'm providing a larger
framework in terms of the ability of
society to respond to pandemic threats
whether it's HIV flu or what-have-you
and to get started here we go so first
of all you have to understand where are
we with global health and how did we get
here we've seen a phenomenal growth in
funding for global health it came over a
very short period of time it was sloppy
it was fast it saw tremendous donor
complexity it was heavily biased towards
treatment medicalize a medicalizing
global health it has been impaired by
the world financial crisis of 2008-2009
and I'm going to walk you through these
key points and explain to you where I
think it's all going and how the ability
of the world to respond to a pandemic
fits in particularly given the many
distractions that political leaders have
at this time and the incoming new
Congress and its budgetary priorities
how that will influence global health so
let's start with sloppy fast sloppy
urgent huge expansion of global health
overnight well I think most of you were
like in junior high school or grammar
school and it is a commitment that began
in the 1990s with a total spending of
about 5.6 billion that covered water
supplies drugs everything the whole
spectrum of what we call global health
it was overwhelmingly public health
until HIV came along and finally got the
attention that it merited but in the
early days only about 300 million
dollars went for all aspects of HIV
condom distribution treatment you name
it as a result the world could be
accused of horrible negligence of not
caring and not showing concern about
millions and millions of people becoming
infected and dying around outside of the
wealthy world it was indeed an unfolding
pandemic that was already out of control
before governments began to seriously
address it and now as the third largest
pandemic in world history and will
shortly eclipse the black death of the
of the Middle Ages leaving swine flu
1918 in the number one position so our
first problem how do you get the
political and economic leadership of the
world to care well it started with w-h-o
which was the big kahuna in the 1980s
and 90s nothing else was on the stage
and they actually walked away from
hiv/aids they shut their program down in
the early 1990s and said the heck with
it it was a huge and unbelievably gross
political venture at the time having
abandon it the global community said
wait a minute this is
something has to come to fore and so
this strange entity was created called
un un AIDS
it's actually a coalition of six United
Nations agencies of which w-h-o is one
piece
it started in 1995 as the first genuine
UN response to the epidemic after the
shutdown of the WHL program and it was
greeted with by most governments with
total denial ok flash-forward where are
we today thanks to a star-studded cast
of businesspeople celebrities and
political leaders we've had a total
explosion in the amount of money brought
to bear
not just for HIV but global health writ
large in settings like Davos and the TED
conferences and World Bank meetings if
you look at the distribution at this
point the global distribution for aids
itself about seven point six billion in
total disbursements in 2009 and the
United States is by far the biggest
giver nothing comes close and there is
an expectation once you've put people on
treatment that that money will be there
every year and continue to flow if you
take health writ large not just HIV
again you see this spectacular growth
growth from all the way up to about
twenty six point four billion dollars by
2008 and again the United States a major
player with the EU the second giant
player on the field how is it
distributed overwhelmingly it's about
HIV that giant blue bar at the top but
also interestingly the giant orange bar
which generally has channel not through
classic health but through development
channels is water systems
what's grossly under deployed is
resources for health care worker
development and training and for the
essential infrastructure of health so
you're piling on this enormous burden
for treatment specifically for HIV and
secondarily for other disorders but
you're not really providing resources to
allow an infrastructure to implement
targets and to train the necessary
healthcare workers regardless of their
sub profession to execute the functions
that you're targeting so this then takes
us to problem number two huge sloppy
expansion of money and it's so complex
this is a chart of u.s. global health
donation under the Bush administration
how would you like to be on the
receiving end of this it's some Ministry
of Health trying to figure out what
agency in Washington is doing the you
know spot checking and is responsible
for the grants that your department has
received and even if you know what
agency it came from the sub agencies are
a bunch of alphabet soups to try and
keep track of and they go channel
through I mean Global Health actually
channels through 43 different agencies
of the United States government it is
not all through health channels most of
it actually comes through the State
Department and as part of the overall
State Department smart power or soft
power programs so recap we've gone from
one agency on the field and the WHL come
finally coming back to since then this
absolute expansion not only of money but
of how many players are on the field and
claim leadership claim the right to
dictate the policy's claim the right to
decide the whole direction and
priorities of global health it's become
so complicated that almost no one can
really keep track of who's deciding what
agendas who's in charge and by the way
just on HIV alone there have been sixty
thousand new NGOs created practically
overnight to deal
just with HIV the majority of them
focused on Africa so if you're at the
Ministry of Health and all these
agencies are coming at you and all these
NGOs are coming at you and they all want
just a little bit of your time and the
right to march into your country and
execute a program that may be in
conflict with your own national policies
it's overwhelming truly overwhelming
well of course the other big player that
jumped into the field starting in 1999
was Bill and Melinda Gates and their
foundation
from the very beginning they were
putting kinds of money quantities out
that we're absolutely overwhelming and
unprecedented in the history of private
giving and total that giant orange chunk
is the health piece of all Bill and
Melinda Gates giving which has now
exceeded 23 billion dollars in a very
short amount of time the vast majority
of it gone out the door just in the last
five years the other new entity the
Global Fund to fight AIDS tuberculosis
and malaria is unique it's a funding
mechanism unlike anything for any
category of problems you may choose to
deal with it's actually a granting
mechanism started dispersing in 2002 by
2003 2008 it was up to 2.3 billion now
it's in a budget crisis has failed to
meet its replenishment goals rather
dramatically so and is unable to fulfill
commitments to countries if you look at
the breakdown of money for the Global
Fund again the United States is the
major donor we give about a third of the
money from our taxpayers and add in what
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
gives and we are by far the major donor
as Americans to that keeps the Global
Fund alive how bad is the shortfall the
Global Fund said to achieve its targets
it needed by 2015 a total expenditure of
20 billion new dollars in fact donors
have come up with only about eleven
point seven billion which means the
shortfall is very dramatic and very
acute and countries will not get what
they need for their malaria TB and HIV
programs which takes us to problem
number three the medicalization of
global health remember I told you it
started out as public health when Obama
came into office he inherited PEPFAR
amongst other programs which was the
President's Emergency Plan for AIDS
relief created by George Bush it was a
brilliant program in the sense that it
moved a lot of money very fast for AIDS
treatment but it had no transparency it
had never been assessed it had no
quality standards so who knew if it was
working or not
who knew if the dollars were well spent
or not we deserve better than that and
so the Obama administration spent about
the first year of the president's first
term assessing PEPFAR and a variety of
other global health programs trying to
come up with a new strategy a more
accountable strategy the first thing
they noticed was that virtually
everything about HIV programs and TVM
malaria was based on cottage industries
tiny minuscule mostly NGO or faith-based
run programs that had been at one
village or one part of one country
perhaps they had indeed worked very well
in that specific cultural setting or
village setting in which they operated
but who knew if they could scale up an
indeed scale up capacity building has
proven a very difficult and moving
target for every aspect of executing a
larger HIV agenda and malaria and TB and
we've not done terribly well on
prevention we have now about thirty five
million people living with hiv/aids 34
million if you take the best estimate
from un AIDS and the numbers keep on
mounting about 2.6 million annually are
newly infected with hiv/aids so we have
as a public health measure failed
entirely with the HIV pandemic well the
new target set by un AIDS is zero zero
new infections zero untreated infections
once they occur getting to that such a
bold target will be a tough one though
we do have new evidence that treatment
lowers transmissibility dramatically so
perhaps if we can more aggressively
treat we can also reduce the spread
despite expansion or treatment however
we continue to have AIDS deaths the
numbers have gone down but here on the
30th anniversary we have to recognize
that we're continuing to fail and UN
AIDS thinks if they can get enough money
and the programs can be adequately
funded which they are not now we might
be able to hold down the new infection
rates now up to a
possibly 75 million people one of the
reasons we're having so much trouble
controlling it is that governments
continue to use non scientific basis for
determining what their HIV prevention
policies will be and this means that 29
to 35 million people so far have died
many of them needlessly so need not have
been infected in the first place but
governments don't like to talk about sex
don't like to talk about IV drug use
don't like to talk about the things that
are actually responsible for spread such
as that one out of every five ID drug
you ID drug users in the world are
already infected with HIV that's a
battle we have lost and we have lost in
every single country in the world
fifteen point nine billion dollars worth
of resources to commit by 2009 to low
and middle income countries with a goal
of getting a million people and more in
universal access we're up to about six
million people in developing countries
now receiving antiretroviral drugs our
primary emphasis then for all this
enterprise related to HIV is on
treatment prevention has taken a distant
backseat and treatment when they first
rolled out PEPFAR in 2003 was thought to
be easy because hey it was just handing
out pills right turns out countries
don't have the absorption capacity for
billions of dollars overnight they don't
even have the banking systems the
finance systems much less the actual
infrastructure of health to spend the
money so money was sitting in bank
accounts unspent and backlogged secondly
we didn't have any gold standard for
achievement so we had no way and we
still don't have a way to say to any
given government or NGO or faith-based
organization this is the model now go
out and implement it and we'll test and
see if you made the gold standard so
everybody's doing it the way they feel
they should do it and judging by their
standards their metrics what
achievements they may or may not have
made and I see that the program is
inserting
odd little gibberish for some reason
into my slides well as they went along
one of the things that everybody got to
certainly by 2006 was wait a minute
we're doing primary health care we
called it handing out pills but hey I'm
an NGO I'm a faith-based group I'm right
here in the middle of chronic disease
management and guess what chronic
disease management has never previously
been a part of anybody's foreign aid
programs so we don't have a model for
how to do that we don't do it for
diabetes we don't do it for cancer care
so let's take a breath and see what we
just did we didn't think about it
consciously we didn't have a strategy we
just did it and boom overnight
we started out global health equals
public health you know vaccines water
supplies the classics and without
thinking about it it's shifted and it
became medical treatment and not only
medical treatment but non curative
lifelong chronic care we medicalised
this entire thing we call global health
we turned it into a medical treatment
model without any conscious strategic
discussion or debate it just happened
now we're saddled with what we did
without really strategically thinking
about it without analyzing and our
thoughts and our plans as we went
forward and what have we discovered well
first of all we don't have any health
care workers and second of all we don't
have an infrastructure so boom we walked
into these waters and discovered that
most poor countries lack the capacity to
execute our grand strategies and you
know infrastructure is not just do you
have a clinic it's do you have a paved
road to get to the clinic the health
care worker crisis is very severe the
best estimates are that we have about 60
million people involved in health as
their profession dentists lab techs
doctors nurses what have you highly
skewed to North America and Europe and
within every country highly skewed to
the cities there are about the deficit
of 4.3 million health care workers with
the most acute deficit being in the
hardest-hit and most
countries of sub-saharan Africa a
deficit of about a million health care
workers but many Asian countries have
extreme deficits and so do a number of
countries in Latin America and the
Caribbean so let's recap we plunge
straight ahead and then we went uh-oh we
don't have health care workers and we
don't have an infrastructure and here we
are the commitments are made we're clear
on this right okay so let's go forward
what happened next and where are we now
well the World Bank suddenly declared
that we'd created a giant what's called
moral hazard argument we had hooked one
ministry of health after another one NGO
program after another on external
funding so that it reached the point
where many governments now have
ministries of health that are more than
50% dependent on external sources of
funding who's calling the shots then who
decides the policies is it the
government of Kenya the government of
Uganda or is it possible that because
they hold the purse strings the Bush
administration says abstinence works and
now you're all going to implement
abstinence policies it doesn't matter
what you think works what your cultural
trends are we've decided we're the
funders now go out there and implement
the program we've decided this is the
classic moral hazard argument and it is
one that now haunts almost every aspect
of global health implementation around
the world particularly in countries that
have very weak infrastructures the
second problem is because we didn't have
a gold standard for what we were trying
to achieve we also don't have an exit
strategy so we haven't been designing
global health programs intended to be
sustainable and eventually completely
handed over to the host governments or
the host NGOs we haven't even thought
about it so how long is this gravy train
supposed to run well boom alarm comes
2008 the world financial crisis and it's
not a silly question anymore it's a very
urgent question how long will the gravy
train last how long does the flow of
cash for this whole exercise come from
what part of the world to the other
we very immediately
some McCobb things happen for example in
Kenya hospitals stopped releasing
cadavers until the families paid off the
hospital bills in China many hospitals
will kick a patient out as soon as their
family runs out of money regardless of
whether their treatment has been
fulfilled we've started to see all sorts
of McCobb distortion effects on local
health provisions not just for HIV but
for all healthcare but the interesting
thing about the 2008 financial crisis is
that it was also the beginning of a
massive restructuring of global
economics because what we experienced as
pain is actually pleasure and delight
for the BRICS countries Brazil China
India the countries that are getting
rich while we're suffering and seeing a
decline in our economic capacities and
this has already resulted in a dramatic
shift in world politics so what used to
be the g8 world with the classic
European Japanese u.s. triangle is now
the g20 world it's their world we just
happen to live in it they're in the
driver's seat and the key drivers are
Brazil China and India they're not just
driving the economy they're driving all
global policies and multilateral
policies which includes much of what we
call global health and they're doing so
while still being recipients of aid so
add to the financial crisis we went into
the world food inflation crisis the
first stage of it began in 2007 and
peaked in mid 2008 with dramatic
increases in costs of basic grains rice
was the big one then we're now in the
stage 2 of the world financial crisis
affecting primarily wheat and corn and
it is devastating in poor countries it's
hurting even here on your financial
wallet the 2008 price increases were
most sharply felt in the poorest
countries surprise surprise and as rice
prices drove upwards in a spiral that
was completely out of control
people realized that we had never really
as a global community addressed food
we'd never really addressed adequately
agricultural capacity
and capacity-building in poor countries
so we had zero resilience before the
crisis hit we were already pressed to
make needs felt for food around the
world once the crisis did hit the
president of the World Bank said 100
million people had overnight been driven
into acute life-threatening poverty by
the increase in food prices in 2008 it
was so dramatic we've never seen
anything like it before
unprecedented it caused riots all over
the world for food Philippines Haiti
Pakistan everywhere you turned I was in
Bangladesh and saw riots breaking out
over access to rice and even as this was
happening the rich world's actual
commitment to both provision of food
resources and agricultural development
went down rather than up and responsive
to the crisis now we're in the second
big one
and we've actually hit the highest
prices for basic foods in world history
either into a direct current dollar
expenditure or evaluated according to
historic dollar values the big driver
this time wheat and corn and that is
secondarily affecting all meat prices
and virtually everything else that you
eat as you can see the red lines are
2011 so we started with a corn price in
2011 that was already higher than
anything except the absolute peak in
2008 and we've now surpassed that corn
prices have increased more than 61
percent this is an old slide for January
the real startling increases have
occurred in the last few months rice is
going up but not quite as dramatically
as in 2008 for a variety of reasons
related to what's being hoarded and
what's the nature of market speculation
in the global commodities market the big
speculation is corn now and the hoarding
is on wheat why is week getting hoarded
because of the great fires of Ukraine
and Russia last summer and the Russian
and Ukrainian government have put a
complete clamp on all exports of
huit why is this happening well one
reason of course is there's more of us
that are hungry more of humans eating
but more importantly happily more and
more of humanity is entering the middle
class and when you become middle class
the first thing you want is meat and
more of it you want a chicken in every
pot you want a steak on Sunday and this
puts tremendous demand on both grain
resources and land resources far more
than the growing of produce the second
problem is that we've never invested in
agricultural development in countries
where women are the farmers that is all
of Africa and most of Southeast Asia so
where women are the labor force they are
farming with the same techniques used
2,000 years ago a hand hoe a baby on the
back and maybe some fertilizer we've
actually seen that investment in those
women has gone down not up in response
to the crisis so if we spend less on
agricultural development we increase
food dependency if people can't grow
their own food and we're not helping
them to learn how
then we're ensuring that every time food
costs inflate the pressure will be
either we starve to death or you start
figuring out how to give us humanitarian
relief so again just as I've already
described to you that dependency is
increasing in global health it's also
increasing at the same time in food
basic food and why am I talking in a
health discussion about food obviously
because if you're not eating
you're unhealthy meanwhile the amount of
land that people could farm is
disappearing overnight we're seeing the
fastest devastation of arable land in
known history
I mentioned the fires that destroyed
wheat crops severe weather events are
becoming more common and are having a
devastating impact on food production
you know the floods in Pakistan and
India last year were larger than the
total size of Western Europe Australia
was under flood in its primary
agricultural zone larger than the size
of Germany and France combined so you
look at the
contributors that are driving this food
dependency slash inflation there are
classic issues there are demand issues
there's market speculation oil prices
affect the cost of fertilizer and the
transport of foods extreme weather
events are becoming more and more common
and more and more severe arable land is
disappearing and with that a lot of
potable water well how did the g20 I
told you they're in the driver's seat
now not the g8 how did they respond to
all of this they held a crisis meeting
in February Nicolas Sarkozy was the
chair they said oh this is so bad
or did you see something about this
that's about it there were some
commitments made some money was going to
flow in certain directions most of it
has never appeared in its targeted
directions and the 22 billion pledged
over three years including the u.s.
portion has largely never materialized
to help poor countries improve their
agricultural capacities and countries
vowed to stop stockpiling and hoarding
and they have not done so by and large
protectionist barriers continue to be
severe and market speculators you know
the guys that brought us the world
financial crisis in the first place are
now wildly speculating in the food price
arena which drives the prices even worse
and there's zero transparency in those
markets now look at the red line that's
2011 that's how where we started with
prices in the beginning of the year
November is usually when pricing Peaks
what in the world our food price is
going to look like this fall if current
trends mean anything here's meat prices
and they're steadily rising it's a good
reflection of both demand and petroleum
costs because of the huge transport
costs associated with getting meat to
the marketplace you can project out and
see a pretty terrifying prospect no one
I know imagines a way that world food
prices come down only flat line or
steadily worse so again the g20 said oh
my goodness we have a
crisis let's meet again had another
meeting in June once again they promise
to be transparent and do something they
did nothing they created a database to
keep track of rising food prices so what
happened corn hit the highest ever in
world history and demand starkly went up
one of the reasons corn is so sensitive
is that about 40% of American corn goes
to feed gas tanks not human beings an
ethanol is driving this inflation
heavily buttocks
Oxfam also has estimated where we're
going to be I don't know if you could
see this in this light but where we're
going to be with food prices due to
climate change impacts severe weather
events and so on the shaded areas are
where food prices will be just the
portion of increased due to climate
change by 2030 and the lower lines are
where we already are see inflation their
estimates are it's going to drive mass
starvation events particularly in
sub-saharan Africa and that it's going
to become more obvious and more severe
every single year primarily not due to
heat as people imagine but severe
weather events ok problem 6
we're overwhelmed and our political
leaders have so much on their agendas
now it's staggering you know start with
the earthquake in Haiti and then an
earthquake in Japan the pandemic of flu
the wars in Afghanistan Iraq and now
Libya it seems an unprecedented level of
catastrophic events that our major
leaders including our president are
saddled with on top of it all huge
indebtedness for us driven heavily by
the cost of two wars Afghanistan and
Iraq now I submitted to have already
costs since 2011 the 2001 scuse me 3.7
trillion dollars and 225,000 lives lost
civilian and military combined this is
from Brown University's cost of war
index an interesting website problem 7
the US political system is a
and now it's a mess that wants nothing
but budget-cutting
a lot of people in America believe that
about 25% of the u.s. budget is sent
overseas it's actually less than 1% of
our US budget goes overseas for anything
other than military goods and it's
shrinking by the microsecond if you look
at it as a pie chart global health
spending under the Obama called the
global health initiative I told you he
redesigned global health spending is a
very trivial portion about 0.8 percent
of the federal budget nevertheless it
has no constituency politically to
protect it so it's very vulnerable to
budget cutting many critics of global
health claimed that the country's
stopped spending if we give them money
and actually the trend shows the
opposite in every region of the world
national spending domestic spending on
health is increasing so even the poorest
countries on the planet are spending
more of their own resources it's not the
case that if we give them money they
stop spending their own so let's drill
down on this Global Health Initiative
that Obama has created and how does it
work and what is it dealing with well of
course it's overwhelmingly about HIV and
I already told you that HIV is
overwhelmingly about treatment versus
prevention if you combine what we give
to the Global Fund the HIV portion of
that plus direct PEPFAR HIV spending
that's about two-thirds of the total PI
of the Global Health Initiative it
called for steady increase in spending
but not at the spectacular pace that
some advocates wanted to see Obama
advocate for we would be spending right
now in fiscal year 2011 9.6 billion but
then we got nervous about a budget ax
coming which I'll get to in a few
minutes we are spending as a percentage
of our GDP very very generously now as
American taxpayers for a long time
Jeffrey Sachs here
from Colombia was criticizing how much
was spent saying that we were not
spending our fair share of GDP to help
the poor of the world but now we are at
that 0.8 percent magic point and there
are only three countries in the world
that donate more as a percentage of
their GDP than we do on HIV is most of
this growth in the amount of money for
HIV is coming from the Gates Foundation
the Global Fund which is as I told you
one-third US taxpayer supported and
direct US taxpayer funding the United
States government that giant dark
section at the bottom so as you can see
I personally look at this as a source of
pride as an American taxpayer some of my
money really is keeping people alive all
over the world at this point American
taxpayers are responsible for 58 percent
of all global HIV programming and 52
percent of global health overall a
source of pride but also a source of
vulnerability think about that very
carefully keep those numbers in your
head more than half of the global pot
and the Gates Foundation is responsible
for 68 percent of all private giving
related to global health on planet Earth
today one foundation calls the shots on
all private giving related to global
health in fact I would argue that the
two Washington's are controlling this
thing we call global health Seattle and
the District of Columbia nothing comes
close to to the impact and influence
these two entities have and to what
would happen if they walked away one
exception David Cameron prime minister
of the UK last week made a massive more
than three billion dollar commitment in
a time of great fiscal difficulty in his
country in fact riots today as all the
school teachers of the UK went on strike
over their austerity programs they have
their own unemployment and recession
difficulties nevertheless he said we owe
it to the world to deal with vaccinating
poor children their money is went to
Gabby and
together with Bill Gates they pushed the
GAVI replenishment this is the Global
Alliance for vaccines and immunization
well past what was the request level of
3.7 billion to 4.3 billion for a total
nut was seven point six billion dollars
for childhood vaccination this has been
Bill Gates big number one priority that
and the eradication of polio but where
does all this leave the World Health
Organization so remember I told you when
I started the talk they used to be the
only game in town and now Margaret Chan
the director is facing a 1 billion
dollar shortfall right this minute she
is having to cut programs right and left
one out of five WH employees is losing
their jobs getting laid off the
organization is shrinking down
dramatically their two-year budget is
less than half of the GAVI budget so
global vaccines uh HIV w-h-o everything
else about health shrinking with this is
a shrinkage of their influence their
policy drive their political leadership
over this enterprise we call global
health to take you back to nineteen
ninety that green bar was w-h-o biggest
game in town second biggest United
States government and our foreign
assistance programs and the some of the
Europeans came in behind that if you
compare the nineteen ninety figures to
where we are today and the entry of all
kinds of new players into the field you
can see that w-h-o again in the green
has shrunken significance US government
way number one but the Global Fund
that's that G fad TM NGOs generally
actually give more and then WH o itself
and you can go on down the list and see
this now what's the trend that I would
forecast for the next three years I see
us support declining thanks to the
Republican Congress with that will come
a decline for the Global Fund a severe
decline for WH Oh
huge increases for the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation's giving us the UK will
continue to modestly increase Gavi will
be the major recipient of this increase
in support but the EU is declining
thanks to greece portugal spain crises
and UNFPA
will see a decline because the united
states will cease backing family
planning and reproductive health
programs now why am i giving you this
horrible look at this it realigns
everything about global health
everything we think we're doing so here
we are we're talking about pandemics if
the FWA chose falling apart we shut down
the National Centre for infectious
diseases at CDC CDC's program for
emergency response is greatly reduced so
who the heck responds in the next
pandemic
if w-h-o is gutted is this our
responsibility taxpayers and if America
are we the ones that are going to fix
this mess not according to the
Republican leadership in Congress Ileana
ros-lehtinen who's of Cuban descent and
sees the number-one priority of all
foreign assistance to bring down Fidel
Castro you laugh but hey it's true has
asked of global health what's the return
on our investment what do we get out of
it nada
shut it down she controls the House
Foreign Operations Committee the head of
the House Appropriations Committee
agrees with her and says I hate the UN
so stop giving any money to any UN
program alright so let me back up one
second make sure you know what set the
stage here where were we a month ago do
you all remember this giant fight on the
continuing resolution for the budget of
2011 they didn't even know what I'm
talking about raise your hand if you
know what I'm talking about
okay some of you don't this is huge
there and almost unprecedent in our
political history the Republican Party
said when the new Tea Party element came
in you know what we're gonna stop the
budget right now no more checks get
written for not next year for the budget
right this minute
no more NIH grants checks get written no
more foreign anything get written while
we continue you have a continuing
resolution to vote on how much
this budget that was already passed
already allocated already approved will
actually go out the door
their goal what they promised as the tea
party campaigners was we're gonna
eliminate a hundred billion dollars from
this year's budget what they actually
did after thrashing about fighting the
white house valiantly standing up to
defend they mainly targeted the State
Department they cut eight 4.4 billion
dollars where the State Department
programs which is where most Global
Health is nested fortunately in this
round most of the key global health
programs were protected and we actually
saw a slight increase overall only sixty
six million compared to last year in
global health funding but to put it in
perspective these dramatic cuts that
they ultimately made represent an
absolutely trivial portion of the
national debt or deficit which of course
were allegedly the targets for this
massive cutting drive right so the real
problem is what's gonna happen now as we
go into the fight over the fiscal year
2012 budget now 2012 budget spending
starts on October 1st of this year the
White House wants a modest increase for
global health a nine point eight billion
dollar for up from nine point six they
want the biggest chunk of increase to go
for family planning programs because
they were completely unserved under the
Bush administration and a lot of
mother-to-child maternal health programs
the GOP reverse wants to cut 1.5 billion
out of global health they want to
eliminate all family planning spending
and they want to cut a billion dollars
out of NIH programming that specifically
goes for research related to global
health problems where is this going to
end up I don't think we can call it
right now but I know that we can say
it's up to you the taxpayers to decide
this leaves us in a dependency cycle
we've got six million people would put
on antiretrovirals we can't suddenly
stop treating them if you do they die we
know we've seen the equation the
experiments been done you stop your anti
retrovirals you die
and usually quickly so this leads us to
ask what exactly is this thing
we're calling global health today the
initiatives are clear like the Gabby
vaccination initiatives that is a very
clear mission you know what it is you
can define it it's very classic vertical
programming you march in you vaccinate
you leave town but WH o is not now
considered a key element of this thing
we call global health it is shrinking
the Global Fund which three years ago
was the sexy thing we call global health
is also shrinking and the Gates
Foundation which I want to underscore
this for a moment it dominates it not
only dominates in terms of being the
biggest private giver it dominates in
setting policy because every single
Global Health Program
now in the world and frankly this whole
school the School of Public Health it
Columbia are utterly dependent on Gates
money and individual sub programs are up
to a hundred percent dependent on Gates
money so the Gates Foundation is setting
policy now for the whole world
they have no accountability they don't
have a board of directors there's no
transparency on any decision on funding
made by the Gates Foundation what's the
weapon the US government as I told you
is the Big Kahuna and if we start
cutting with the budget acts on us
support it will have an immediate impact
finally we're heading towards September
when there will be a United Nations
General Assembly special session to talk
about diverting all our attention
towards non communicable diseases so
called NC DS the classic chronic
diseases that are on the rise as more
and more countries enter the age of
affluence diabetes cancer heart disease
mental health problems you know all the
classic set of chronic disease issues
that we face here in the United States
the problem is the recipes for solutions
to the non communicable disease set are
far more complicated put you right up
against the food industry right up
against the tobacco industry right up
against a whole host of issues for which
we've never really had
easy solution even here in the United
States much less a global solution and
on top of it
what about crises severe weather events
earthquakes bioterrorism is this all
global health and who's making those
choices what is global health we have
seen such a dramatic shift occur with
such rapidity that I don't think if we
took a poll in this room we would have a
solution we would agree so who decides
it is it Bill Gates is it Ileana Ross
laitanan did this does the g20 define
global health to the least development
country governments to find does is it
USAID or diff it or oacd is there such a
thing as a health consumer out there
that decides the definition of global
health is it you here in this room we
don't have a mechanism we're just
letting it happen haphazardly without
any strategic thinking and when you look
at it given the severe shortage of
health care workers and the
infrastructure to support it you can
very clearly see everything skew towards
two giant initiatives vaccinating kids
and HIV treatment this takes us to
ultimately our real background problem
we are really good at charity we're not
very good at maintenance sustainability
long-term survival of any of our
programs overseas and I just want to
finally go to the Department of
shameless advertising as you heard I
have a new book coming out it'll be
available on Amazon in two weeks and it
looks at 911 and anthrax thank you
thank you very much to our distinguished
and always articulate speaker for that
fascinating talk the floor is now open
for questions please use the microphone
so everybody or I'll shout so everybody
can hear oh you do need to use the
microphone cuz they're filming it if you
take private and public giving by nation
what percentage of GDP is US versus
other nations Oh as I said we're at 0.8
percent of GDP Oh private giving sorry
very good point
okay we're at 0.8 percent of GDP for
public giving if you add in our private
giving and we are by far the most
generous private givers on earth it well
takes us over the 1 percent of GDP level
so that would be ahead of the other
absolutely ok this the second one was
not really a question was a point we
don't take a lot of money from the Gates
Foundation here and the reason is
because the indirect cost strategy so
you don't if you cannot cover the bills
that are associated with taking the
money you can't take it so there is very
modest gate support of Columbia well
that may be true at Columbia but I know
that the Gates Foundation is the major
supporter of most schools of Public
Health
outside of bench research areas what I
just stun you into absolute violence
come on what is global health guys so
that's the way in which Columbia is
unique anyway is that what is global
health what do you guys think here comes
some brave soul not to answer your
question but I was just wondering if
there's if you've seen an upsurge in
donations from these new emerging
company countries brick and I know the
Gulf Cooperation Council for example
gives I mean the government state that
they give billions and billions of
dollars a year and yeah well how much
goes to setting up Wahhabi schools and
how much goes up to to public right this
is unknown but um is there any shift
among sort of Brazil India China so this
is a very important question you're
asking because as you know at the moment
China controls most of the world's debt
and certainly most of our debt and it
has the largest supply of cash on planet
Earth
India and Brazil to a lesser degree
Russia's totally for reasons of energy
and resources and of course all the oil
countries have vast reserves of wealth
at this moment and ironically China
remains one of the top recipients of
global fund support for their HIV
programs and India continues to be a
recipient of global health support both
India and China have come under sharp
criticism for that in the last six to
nine months and have started to make
very public announcements about programs
in which they're giving funding they're
giving support for global health but it
still isn't as much as they're receiving
and it's an odd dilemma I think we'll
work through it but at this moment in
the g20 context you have almost a
blatant contradiction and I think it
part is to be fair I don't think that a
country grows up overnight from absolute
poverty to a major economic powerhouse
and with a sense of global citizenry
built in to the the whole sort of fiber
of the country that doesn't happen
overnight it certainly didn't happen
with us we were not a foreign aid donor
for more than the first hundred years of
the existence of the United States
so although we of course did donate to
manipulate wars that were to our
advantage so you know we have to be fair
about our expect
but also let's keep in mind that China
and India in particular have tremendous
health disparities domestically with a
lot of people locked into the infectious
disease threat era not yet making the
health transition so they have a tall
order to achieve domestically as well as
becoming Global Health Partners so sorry
I'm not I'm also not up here to answer
your question I have a question of my
own so so earlier just going back to an
earlier section of your talk you
mentioned many inherent flaws in the
global public health system that we have
today
like this problem of the moral hazard
which came a little later but also no
exit strategies no gold standard things
like this and you also said that they
dated back to problems like there was no
supervision this sort of happened
overnight in no one really understood
who was in charge but you also mentioned
later that while it's sort of diminished
and been shrunk in size the World Health
Organization back then was the primary
contributor and it sort of coordinated
all of its eff all of these efforts so
how is it possible that the World Health
Organization would have allowed this
sort of transformation this like
medicalization of global public health
right under their very noses if they
were still in control at the time Wow I
mean first of all I'm stunned at how
well you paid attention to my remarks
you perfect recap and your question is a
good one um when often when I try to
explain to people in the general public
not people with some college level
interest in public health that the state
today of w-h-o they're stunned and they
can't understand how this could have
happened what what in the world is going
on there and of course the answer is a
bit complicated but it begins with with
a real arrogance institutionally by
w-h-o back in the 1980s and 90s it was a
it was the the only game in town
they decided everything if any rival
even tried to get into the field w-h-o
squashed him like a little bug and
unfortunately at that time
of great power and wealth good funding
and so on WH I became a victim of its
own unique governance structure so WI
chose the only UN agency that actually
has a legislative body and by charter
answers to a legislative body it's not a
very resilient or rapid agency as a
result because the legislative body the
World Health Assembly only convenes once
a year and then when it does convene
often getting any kind of ruling passed
is just a nightmare and can take you
know two weeks three weeks of you know a
bizarre process in which a tiny country
like Vanuatu has an equal proportional
vote to China and that means that
Vanuatu could literally block
legislation if you will through the
World Health Assembly that affects five
or six billion human beings on top of
that long ago w-h-o agreed to a regional
structure creating eight regional
offices for us does they may know the
name of our regional office PAHO the
pan-american Health Organization which
actually precedes the existence of
whu-oh but became the w-h-o regional
office the regional offices have become
more and more powerful time and in some
cases literally just ignore what Geneva
tells him to do and Margaret Chan can
say all she wants you know do X Y or Z
and they just say Nina we're down in
Brazzaville ha ha ha and so the kind of
power struggle has worsened over time
internally in w-h-o and then finally the
coup de Gras is that along with that
sort of governance structure is if you
will a taxation structure so that
country's proportional to their GDP are
expected to give a certain amount of
money annually as members of w-h-o and
that's meant to be the core budget of
the institution so 193 nations
give various amounts of money the
problem is that long ago the taxation
system ceased being adequate to support
even the core functions of w-h-o and so
the wealthy countries became earmark
donors and I'm sure if you think about
the US Congress you all know what's
wrong with earmarking right you
understand what earmarking is it means
that ultimately the United States can
say you know we'd like to see a
nutrition program and to aggressively
get the world interested in nutrition so
we're going to give another billion
dollars a year to w-h-o to build up a
whole you know nutrition Empire but by
the way as Americans the way we define
nutrition is set by McDonald's right so
all of a sudden the outside earmarked
special programming is way more than the
core budget and w-h-o itself isn't
calling the shots on what's that
priorities of those programs and then I
think as I suggested in my remarks that
the crucial mistake that set whu-oh on
this path was getting rid of their
hiv/aids program and walking away from
the greatest pandemic of since the
existence of wh oh thanks I guess so
I'll hazard a definition as part of my
question good freedom so what is global
health in the actual world I'm just
watching your presentation it looks a
lot upsettingly so a lot like the US
health system it's a bunch of disparate
programs in completely cobble together
and you know the question stems from
this you've really presented a very
catastrophic picture and I want to ask
you know I and a lot of people in here
are researchers or interested in
research I know just from experience
that research doesn't usually dictate
policy but nevertheless I mean do you
have a recommendation what can we as
researchers or even citizens do I mean
what is the next step after recognizing
catastrophe well I mean
and I'm thank you for asking that and
and here's I think the answer we are
fortunate that we live in this thing
called a democracy and we're those of us
that live in New York are fortunate that
our representative pool both in the
House and the Senate is a reasonably
smart or there's among them some
reasonably smart individuals they need
to hear from you they need to know that
global health and overseas development
are are not things you cut without
paying a price see the reason all these
overseas programs are always the first
thing that you get rid of it's sort of
like the reason at the local level
public health is what city governments
get rid of when they start feeling a
tight budget it's that you don't see the
reason you needed it until there's a
crisis because when it's all working
nothing bad has happened
you know this there's no cell Manila in
the grocery market food if our city
health department is on the job and
there's no polio spreading from Pakistan
to the United States if global health is
on the job right it requires a special
kind of politician to see the need for
that infrastructure when they don't feel
the crisis when there's not a
catastrophe to use your word so I you
know Chuck Schumer really needs to know
that that you feel he will pay a price
politically if he lets this stuff go
down your Congressman needs to know that
or congresswoman they all need to know
that and if you have relatives that live
in you know red states we really need
them mobilized you need to be on the
phone talking to friends and family all
over America are emailing them or
whatever tweeting like mad to make them
understand that they have to make the
their political leaders shiver with fear
good a good example of a creative effort
Ileana ros-lehtinen is the most powerful
in the house on this problem
she comes from Miami outside Miami
surprise surprise
she was born in Cuba she's heavily
supported by the Cuban American
community and she married a into a
Zionist family so she's like a double
whammy
she's Rara Israel I hate Palestine she's
bring down Castro and turn all foreign
assistance into regime change and this
sounds pretty grim how are you ever
gonna get global health on her agenda
but bread for the world which is a
pretty remarkable faith-based
organization spread out all over the
United States has started mobilizing
members of her congregation in and to
get them to say we see it as a religious
duty to you know be our brother's keeper
to share our wealth with the poor of the
world and to put pressure on her right
there in her backyard I think this is
our hope the rest of the world is
counting on us to do this and if we
can't then we let them all down
thank you and you mentioned land
devastation and you know add to that
other global environmental devastation
and how that relates to health and
relates Public Health relates to global
health in many many ways
and I'm wondering from your perspective
what organizations globally are looking
at this at the change whether due to
climate change or whether due to human
activities how that is influencing well
point out Oxfam is on the spot but there
are there are dozens and dozens of
groups actually I mean the
News is that there is now a considerable
amount of attention to the impacts of
climate change and catastrophic weather
events the bad news of course is that
some major I would say ethical errors
were committed by some key environmental
scientists that resulted in a backlash
against the whole climate agenda and so
there's a lot of rebuilding lost ground
in that area and there's an interesting
article word I just read it about Al
Gore where did I just read this was it
in yesterday's New York Times know that
Al Gore himself is acknowledging that he
strategically a made a series of
mistakes that have given ground to the
there is no such thing as climate change
people thank you very much I think a lot
of the discussion was actually on
funding and funding forms one side of a
coin I'm just wondering whether can we
be looking at cost as well what's your
view on the cost of treatment per person
is it going down was it going down fast
enough especially say in a case of AIDS
treatment that's my first question and a
second question I've got relates to
pharma companies what is the role of
pharma companies in terms of helping the
world to treat the global health problem
so the good news is that indeed
pharmaceutical costs for HIV drugs have
gone down dramatically and we hit a bump
in the road about a year ago as more and
more people who've been put on primary
antiretroviral therapy developed
resistant virus needed second line
therapy and costs weren't budging but
again some dramatic interventions in the
last Oh nine months or so have seen
those costs come down as well and we do
have a broader range of producers we
were very dependent on one generic
producer in India to provide low cost
but it's really spreading out now and
we're getting a diversity of low-cost
generic
manufacturers which is all good news
your second question about pharma is is
a one that we actually were having a
healthy argument or discussion about in
seminar just before I came in here oh it
wasn't even an argument anyway was a
discussion oh and you know Pharma I
think there's two things going on at
once first of all I think Pharma itself
is in crisis just its own capitalist
model its own profit Center model is in
crisis most pharma companies are not
going to be able to show the kind of
returns on investment that their stock
investors have counted on for the last
15 years there their main blockbuster
drugs are all coming off patent across
the board and they don't have much in
the pipeline so they're struggling
they're fighting for survival and
they're playing dirty along the way and
there's a lot of unsmurfy stupid things
that drug companies have been doing to
try and protect their market positions
now the smarter among them are beginning
to take a new kind of strategy that may
pose a new set of problems it's it's so
novel that it's unfolding right now and
we'll see how it plays out but they're
beginning to feel that their real market
place of the future is in the BRICS
countries so the battlefield is on
market position for the sale of your
drugs whether they're off label or not
whether they're still patented or not
inside China inside India inside Brazil
inside Mexico inside Indonesia and so on
and those countries of course say well
wait a minute we don't want you to come
in and undermine our local manufacturing
capacity so there's a power and market
battle going on inside the emerging
market countries I don't think you can
say what it'll look like in five years
it's just very new power-struggle
different countries are trying to handle
it in various ways some have passed
pretty darn tough tariff laws and you
used compulsory licensing and other
mechanisms to keep the higher priced
american-made or European or Japanese
made product out of their marketplace
but we also see some really distortion
impacts coming from other directions one
of the ones that I find the most
disturbing and I don't have a real
obvious answer for it we had a fantastic
breakthrough in meningitis a vaccination
huge in the last three months all the
control trials everything that seals
broken unbelievable this is the holy
grail of meningitis vaccination that
we've been searching for for twenty
years it's way cheaper than any
currently available meningitis vaccine
problem the government's are not buying
it and they're not buying it because the
old crappy meningitis vaccine is
subsidized and so this brilliant new
innovation is going unused if you think
about that and project forward with some
of the other things in the pipeline that
are coming through because of gates
investment or path another NGO efforts
or even at things at the NIH that could
be very disturbing down the road if
we've created market distortions because
of global health donation to ministries
of health that actually keep better
innovations out of the marketplace I
thought thank you again for coming to
speak with us today and I just wanted to
ask a question about the human resources
for a health issue that you brought up I
know you moderated the panel at on June
9th about the can we achieve MD g6 with
the workforce that we have today and I
guess I was at wanted to know what you
thought were the biggest challenges with
human resources for health is it
migration of trained professional
is it not training enough professionals
is it you know task-shifting that we
should be focusing on and how do we
address those issues and move forward
with them well of course it's all of the
above but the the problem with the
health care worker crisis is that both
the origins of it and the solutions of
it are highly variable there is not a
answer for the planet you have to almost
go country by country to understand the
picture we have an acute shortage of
healthcare workers in the United States
and our shortages due to a mix of
inadequate levels being trained up in
inadequate funding for nursing schools
in particular which tend to be
land-grant university schools and you
know certain market decisions made about
setting caps on the numbers of doctors
doctor candidates admitted to medical
schools in order to not let the market
place and that sort of thing so we're
actively recruiting healthcare workers
from poor and middle-income countries
around the world
Emira I was in the Bahamas and went to
what is the largest nursing school in
the Caribbean and this was about seven
years ago and the head of the school
said that almost a hundred percent of
the newly graduated class had gone
straight to the United States and these
people had been supported by Caribbean
government taxpayers and ended up you
know being that lovely Caribbean accent
you hear at the nurse's station in
Dallas so that's that's one piece of it
and the brain drain piece is very very
real you know Ross Lee Ross Perot used
that term the big sucking sound the big
sucking sound is the rich countries
sucking poor health care workers from
poorer countries but there's another
piece to it which is the cost of
training so Canada which keeps trying to
do the right thing
the last data said I saw indicated that
only 27% of Canadian doctors were born
and trained in Canada so the vast
majority of physicians practicing in
Canada were born and/or trained in
countries where the cost of training up
a doctor is far lower than the costs in
Canada that primarily means India so you
have this tidal wave of Indian doctors
showing up here but what's happening
back home in India and I think the other
piece that often gets overlooked is
working conditions you know if you're in
Malawi today and you're an MD you will
be absolutely overwhelmed by HIV in your
practice by tuberculosis in your
practice by seeing a lot of death
way more than American physicians see
and with constant resource scarcities
with none of the toolkit that you may
have had the opportunity to get trained
to use in the UK or the United States
but you know there's no cat-scans
there's no MRIs all these fancy schmancy
things and so there's a real morale
problem it's hard to keep well-trained
individuals working under those
conditions and and then when you just
finally add to it that they may become
infected
whenever the barrier protections are
minimal or underfunded so that they're
risking their lives to practice medicine
to be a nurse
to be a lab technician in a resource
poor country where control of infectious
disease spread nosocomial a is is
minimal or or non-existent so you put
all this together it's a pretty grim
picture it's a big challenge there isn't
time to train up enough doctors there
isn't time to train up enough nurses so
a lot of the health care worker crisis
is going to have to be solved through
innovative approaches to community
health workers so one kind or another
and I think the place
we're seeing the most rapid innovations
for that or both in midwifery and in
dealing with HIV and TB I don't think
you can build a whole primary healthcare
system however on the backs of a very
poorly paid semi-literate woman living
in a rural village in a desperately poor
country there's going to have to be more
innovative thinking and I hope that some
of you will get engaged in that show you
have a question you mentioned like wh oh
and how different partners and who's big
in the game do you see like private
public partnerships like how is it
possible in the future for these players
to be collaborative in the future and
what will it take for them to to be
collaborative and support well the best
funded giant is a public-private
partnership Gaby any place where the
Gates Foundation has more than 20% role
you have a public-private partnership
many of the drug companies got into the
business of being a collaborator in a
PPP for PR reasons back when they were
really under the gun for their pricing
schemes on antiretrovirals but some of
them stayed the course and have taken
more serious efforts Botswana is
probably the biggest recipient of
successful PPP that is countrywide for
all aspects of HIV and TB care a
collaboration between Merck the Botswana
and government itself the Global Fund
and the Gates Foundation and the result
is they have universal access to
antiretroviral therapy and they're one
of the few countries in the world that
do I think I'm talked out one last
question recently the Supreme Court made
some ruling that benefits generic drug
makers how will that affect the world
health situation
I don't think I can really answer that
because I never read that Supreme Court
ruling in detail so I don't really know
well how do you think generic did the
role that they play in general obviously
generic manufacturing is the best way to
get prices down
unfortunately the initiative I'm working
on now with the governments of Brazil
the United States China and the UK that
we hope to bring to the level of the g20
in the next round
it concerns a whole separate problem
that affects both the generic and patent
industries very dramatically and that is
that we've seen in the last five years a
dramatic I mean catastrophic surge of
the engagement of organized crime in
pharmaceuticals and over-the-counter
drugs and vitamins pretty much the whole
range of what we call medicines so that
Nigeria now estimates 70% of all
treatment medications sold in Nigeria
are fraudulent products the world we've
seen this huge dependency shift in terms
of raw ingredients which affects whether
you're a generics manufacturer in Brazil
as I was just talking to them last week
or you know Merck over there in New
Jersey that we're all dependent on the
same finite pool of raw ingredients for
the pharmaceutical industry and it turns
out in a smart play India and China have
completely taken over the raw
ingredients market so 100 percent of
salicylic acid comes from China every
time you take an aspirin you're taking a
little bite of China do you think it's
right do you think it's working do you
think it's safe guess what they have no
quality control they have no inspections
a hundred percent of ascorbic acid
vitamin C does not come from the United
States anymore so every time you take a
vitamin C tablet you're trusting that
aid government overseas somewhere
actually tested it and we've we're
getting an increase
in problems associated with fraudulent
raw ingredients and formulated products
and even if they're not fraudulent if
they're suboptimal if the dosage is
suboptimal and your you have a chronic
disease that needs careful management it
could in the long haul
kill you the generics bring down make
these treatments more available to
people in poor countries yeah I said
that well I think what's largest generic
drug manufacturer in the world you know
I don't know right now I thought it
whatever yeah is that one of the largest
generic manufacturers in the world I'm
not sure it's the largest one it's one
of the largest yeah what's your point my
point is that when you blame zionists
are people who support Zionists as being
bad for the health of the world that is
it that you did no I did not tell you
what you said and you tell me ever you
hear if you said that you said yes I'll
tell you what you said you said that
woman from Florida she's a double whammy
what's the double whammy she's against
Castro and she married a super Zionist
yeah so I don't get the logic of your
question but anyway I think I'm done
because I'm logic of your question is
that if you look at the number of
patents in medicine and the a that
Israel gives throughout the world and if
you look at TEVAR
which is a gigantic generic manufacturer
which brings down and makes these things
available I don't think you should blame
Zionism as are people who are Pro
Zionism is one of the factors that are
double whammies and are bad for world
health thank you thank you for those
remarks and please join me in thanking
Laurie Garrett for those incisive and
stimulating remarks